one of the most common questions I see
in the comments of these videos is where
do I start my microscopy Journey what
kind of microscope should I get if I'm
just starting out well that is the very
question we were trying to answer when
we created the microcosmos microscopes
developed in partnership with our master
of microscopes James Weiss they are a
fantastic entry-level microscope and it
is available with either plan achromatic
objectives or regular achromatic
objectives over at
microcosmos.store slash microscope and
you might be thinking I don't know what
an objective is and I sure don't know
what a plan objective is or why you'd
want to upgrade your microscope with
them well we have a bunch of information
about that over there as well and also a
bunch of videos about how to use your
microscope when it arrives also if you
previously purchased a microcosmos
microscope and would like to upgrade
your objectives we have a four pack of
plan objectives for sale separately as
well as brand new 20x and 60 explain
objectives that can be purchased
individually you can get all of that and
more at microcosmos.store
foreign
[Music]
our master of microscopes James was in
fact not always a master like everyone
else he had to start somewhere and that
somewhere was a microscopy lab course
where he saw a scene quite similar to
this one
there were thousands and thousands of
teeny tiny things that he didn't know
well enough to identify and these
minuscule unknown creatures were
behaving oddly they were gathering
together on the side of the slide so
tightly that it looked like they were
trapped by invisible walls anytime one
of them tried to swim away and Escape
those walls it would quickly reverse its
direction and swim right back like
you're leaving the house and then you
realize that it's raining and cold and
you immediately turned back inside in
that comparison you are making an active
decision to turn back but for James new
to the wondrous world of microbes it was
hard to imagine why the creatures would
act like that so he asked his instructor
what was going on but the teacher just
said that he was looking at some
bacteria and did not elaborate as you
can imagine this was not a very helpful
answer but it wasn't completely
unhelpful either after all before this
James had just imagined microbes as
amorphous blobs that sit around and get
you sick but seeing something like this
quickly shatters that image it makes the
bacteria and the other residents of the
microcosmos seem so much more alive and
aware than you'd expect from you know a
blob well that's because microbes are
not just blobs they are very
well-evolved biological Machinery a
product of eons of evolution that have
exposed their ancestors and them to
different homes and foods and threats
the machine that James was watching in
action there was the flagellum a long
helical filament that either drives the
bacteria towards an area or tumbles it
away based on the chemical it senses in
the environment the bacteria does this
with proteins on its surface which then
send a signal through the cell to
control the flagellar motor this motor
then controls the movement of the
flagella which controls the movement of
the cell
and as we watch more complex organisms
we can see a similar Behavior like this
euplodis it feels wrong to even compare
them to a machine because they seem so
cognizant of everything around them even
without access to all of the senses that
we have available to us but they don't
have those senses because they don't
need them these microbes that we are
watching have the same underlying
capacity to assemble Behavior out of
proteins and ions and signals that our
bodies do in fact our senses and
awareness are built with those same
fundamental pieces they're just
assembled on different scales of size
and time and complexity so even though
the pieces are always the same the scale
of behavior and decisions are vast when
you consider all of the organisms out
there and all of the choices they must
be facing every single day but we
journeyers through the microcosmos are
fortunate that scientists have been very
curious about a few species in
particular and the choices they seem
capable of
one species that has been particularly
interesting to learn from is our
favorite trumpet-shaped protists the
stenters
Hunters have kind of an odd problem for
the microcosmos they are very big so big
that they actually have to contend with
non-microcosmos Predators like fish and
worms and insect larvae to deal with
that challenge stenter caruleus has an
ingenious solution if it touches
something it curls up in a ball
it's a great solution lovely even a
little bit cute if a threat approaches
you curl up into a ball and what can it
really do then except that there's a
problem a bunch of them really when
you're living in a pond surrounded by
other organisms that aren't fish how do
you survive if you're constantly curling
up into yourself wouldn't that get
tiring we can see our stunters here are
mostly relaxed so how do they do that
how do they figure out what contact is
non-threatening
they learn through a process called
habituation if something touches the
stenter it will contract away from the
force but if that Force happens again
and again and again and especially if
the force is not that strong the stenter
becomes less and less likely to contract
and stentors are able to remember this
for several hours but as much as
scientists have watched stentors learn
and remember the mechanism that makes
them capable of this is still mysterious
to us
another organism that scientists love to
watch learn is slime mold in one set of
experiments scientists watched slime
mold move towards food through different
temperature and humidity conditions once
an hour the scientists would expose the
Slime to cold dry air during which the
slime mold would slow down when they
were done with the cold exposure and
returned to moist warm conditions the
slime mold would pick its feedback up
the scientists repeated this three times
and then they left the slime molds alone
keeping them in the warm temperatures
that the organisms prefer but even
though the scientists were no longer
switching things back to cold the slime
molds would an hour later slow down
again as if they remembered what had
happened and expected it to get cold
again some would even do it again two
and three hours later like stenters we
don't know the machines that make this
memory and behavior possible but we are
of course drawn to that mystery like
bacteria drawn towards an invisible
gradient we return again and again to
the questions that we have not yet
answered can these organisms think and
remember what does it mean to think at
all are these organisms just machines
and if so are we just machines the
result of chemical reactions that we do
not control or are we something more the
answers to that probably cannot be found
in the microcosmos alone but that is no
reason not to look
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us
and if you are interested in exploring
that world on your own I will remind you
there's a link in the description to the
microcospost microscope in microscope we
made specifically for people who are
starting off on their Journey it can be
a little bit complicated and
intimidating at first but that
microscope comes along with a few things
to help you on your journey including a
mount for your phone so you can video
whatever you're seeing and also a series
of videos that we made to help you get
the best out of your microscope
the people on the screen right now are
our patreon patrons there are a bunch of
people who think that there should be
weird chill content about microscopic
organisms on YouTube obviously we agree
with them but we could not do this on
our own so we are so grateful to all of
the people who help us out at
patreon.com journey to micro if you'd
like to see your name up here that is
the place to go if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes James
Weiss you can check out jam and germs on
Instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's probably a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
thank you
[Music]